Shayne Irving is back in the man cave
here as we recap his picks from last
week I've got you - and - you said that
if it went to 9 the Texas line went to 9
you would take Texas did it get to 9 oh
yeah I got to 9 Danny all right then you
went 3 & 2 which makes you hang biscuit
18 17 and 1 on the season you had
Memphis beating Navy straight up you won
that one a wheel of punishment at stake
with Paulie and C you did lose a wheel
of punishment last week and as a result
you have to sing the Redskins fight song
you being a die-hard cowboy family now
are you ready for them I just want to
have a disclaimer if I may okay I take
exception to this wheel of punishment I
think it's a rude and inconsiderate I
would have done a whole lot other thing
I could have talked about the ginger
nicely for an hour before I sing this
crap it is a wheel of punishment though
it's called punishment all right are we
ready for this do we have music for I
better have me okay here we go
[Music]
hail to the Redskins hail victory Braves
on the warpath hail victory Braves on
the warpath
fight for oldc run or pastured score we
want a lot more beat'em swamp them
touchdown let's point score fight on
Fight on until you have one sons of
Washington will shut it down there
that's good
that ain't right neither sorry put my
best foot forward
you did well considering all right here
we go
this week's picks and then we'll have
another wheel of punishment pictage
spell so who do you have I got too many
Danny this is a dangerous I just want to
put it out there that the million dollar
better is up a million bucks right now
following Shea and Irving right here on
the radio okay I got South Bama -5 Notre
Dame I got -3 I like it Danny okay
d'Arnaud Lincoln do nothing zona minus 3
Tulsa minus 6
I got Wyoming plus 14 Baylor plus 9
and that's a wrap Danny okay now Paulie
in seat mo now we're talking do you have
a wheel of punishment bet for this week
before you guys spin the wheel to
punishment for your loss last week
can you guys is there a consensus pick
we want to do we want to get the cash
back again we want to make some more
money off this I think Shea and Irving
should be the one who offers it up yes
yeah I agree yeah I'm gonna let you
offer it up and see if the dentists are
in now it's either cash or wheel you
guys have to decide Paulie what's our
number right now you owe us a hundred so
this can get you back to even Big Boy or
get me up a hundred pounds on the number
we put on it doesn't it boy okay here we
go all right so we want to hear our five
days here at come on let's go we will
take Syracuse getting 17 at Miami
unbelievable Miami's fraudulent I'm not
taking that there
yeah I don't watch you'll win as hell
yeah we'll take yours see what you got
that's all you got that's that's our
prize oh it's go time
hmm Tulsa minus 6 I'm taking Tulsa minus
6 you got to go the other way plus 6
wait who are they playing I have my
thing down red the other day where the
hell'd that go
I love the crumpled up piece of paper
yeah this is gold this is gold this is
might as well be money right here I
don't remember who the hell they're
playing my phone I turn my phone off
Danny who Tulsa plays Tulsa is at UConn
yeah still have a team yeah yeah besides
lacrosse and field hockey they got this
in women's basketball you don't talk
about my state ok we'll take that 450 no
no I'm not doing it to do a bit okay
doing it that's below you're not doing
it we were gonna take Penn State given
nine and a half to Michigan no not going
khaki anymore communist Paulie
we'll take UConn we'll roll with on a
hundred bucks a hundred or wheel to
punishment on D on D you don't want a
wheel punishment no Danny I don't ever
want to see that thing again another
punishment for sure okay okay relax
let's get through this one cuz y'all are
in together all right here we go
so that'll be $400 you can get again
twenty six six points else is gonna
light that up like a Christmas tree time
to spin the wheel of punishment front
row let's see the I want to Danny yeah I
want to know about the categories what
the only accept and what could you
denied a bunch of them okay we have
Paulie has to wear a Walter Payton's
overrated t-shirt yep Paulie and seaton
have to wear yoga pants yep
somebody has to sit next to Fritzi for
an entire show yep they you're allowed
to control the music for the entire show
no yeah and is there another one on
there only vegetables for meat Friday
for the rest of the year for the rest of
the year I mean we can't do that that
affects me I'll shut it down
and all this all shut down your body
will shut down okay for how long then
what we got to stipulate that two weeks
all right so two weeks all right
Pauling you want to spin the wheel of
punishment here Dan the idea of the
Walter Payton t-shirt thing has given me
a stomachache but I'm going to spin it
good okay
come on veggies come on veggies no I
want the t-shirt veggies Oh No ah only
vegetables 14
Wow
that's falling that's that's a kick in
the yeah that was devastating can I
better dip the vegetables anything no
we're not
so the the big bet this weekend no wheel
of punishment attached is Connecticut
against Tulsa who else would care about
this but us Shane Irving we'll see you
next week
good luck with your Cowboys this week
against the 49ers cries don't screw up
in San Francisco there all right dick
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]